jean marc bonjour
merci olivier heureux de vous retrouver
ce matin dans la matinale de rtl france
testing massif vous comme moi on le voit
tous les jours les files d'attentes
s'allongent et à l'entrée des pharmacies
pour obtenir des tests à la france elle
a décidé de savoir exactement qui
étaient contaminés par quoi jean-marc ça
coûte une fortune
mais avant pour quelle raison la france
a choisi de se faire tester ainsi
massivement c'est vrai vous avez raison
sur un peu d'humour doigt en direction
tester - il y aura peut-être moins de
contamination dans les chiffres du moins
non la vérité c'est que les français
n'ont pas pu faire autrement quand la
vague omicron a commencé à déferler un
peu avant les fêtes souvenez vous les
français se sont fait tester pour éviter
de créer des clusters dans les familles
leurs bérets en familiale et on s'est
aperçu très vite que les gens non
vaccinées étaient vulnérables certes
mais on s'est aussi aperçu que les gens
vaccinés pouvaient être contaminées et
donc contagieux donc on préférait sa
bande dont il était au final on a
détecté des contaminés et après avoir
testé les sujets contacts et bien on a
eu des contacts des contacts et de fil
en aiguille on est arrivé assez assez
assez nombre de de testing de
contamination très important
parallèlement à cette vague de tests les
autorités de santé ont voulu savoir quel
était le variant comme vous le disiez
est-ce que c'était du delta est ce que
c'était de l'eau mikron parce qu'en
fonction du var y en a on avait une idée
de la gravité du cas depuis les
autorités ont cherché à tracer le léguer
le virus derrière puis à nous demander
d'isolement et à compter les cas graves
donc testé traçage isola isolement c'est
à ce moment là que au moment de noël on
a vu s'ouvrir des centres de dépistage
l'objectif de tout ça était de prévoir
ce qui allait se passer dans les
hôpitaux et notamment dans les services
d'urgences qu éviter l'engorgement
éviter le thé essayer de faire un
testing le plus tôt possible pour éviter
cet encombrement des salles de
réanimation alors combien ça coûte ces
tests et qui les paient à écouter ça
coûterait le chien globalement les tests
montrent une fortune on parle d'un
milliard d'euros sur un mois ça ferait
12 milliards c'est donc considérable sur
l'année la trois séries de tests alors
maintenant pour votre bien les connaître
il ya les tests pcr
ils sont les tests j'allais dire les
plus sérieux entre guillemets faut
passer en laboratoire l'analyse demande
près de 24 heures c'est les tests dont
on a besoin pour passer à l'étranger ou
pour faire le le pass scène et hier et
pour confirmer une contamination mais si
on déteste aussi qui permettent le
séquençage c'est à dire qu'ils vont
permettre ou qui permettrait de savoir
d'où vient la contamination
est-ce que c'est du delta où est ce que
c'est de l'eau mikron c'est parce qu'on
est là qu'on s'est aperçu d'ailleurs que
omicron devenait majoritaire en france
et notamment dans l'île de france et est
coûte 65 euros ils ont baissé de moi qui
l a récemment à 35 euros parce qu'on
s'est aperçu que ça coûtait énormément
d'argent et parfois aux passions
deuxième type de test les antigénique
alors on les fait chez les médecins ou
dans les pharmacies d'où ces files
d'attentes que vous avez actuellement
devant tout et les pharmacies aux
alentours de 23 euros on a le résultat
au bout d'un quart d'heure alors que les
tests pcr dont je vous parlais faut
quand même attendre 24 heures souvent un
troisième type de tests via sont les
autotests qui sont aussi antigénique
selon le même procédé que l'on fait soi
même il coûte dans les rues dans les 5
euros va tenez je vous en ai acheté un
là pour pouvoir vous testez puisque moi
je sors d'un coville je suis obligé de
me tester pratiquement tous les jours ça
coûte à peu près 5 euros sont des tests
qui sont utilisés notamment pour les
enfants quand ils sont quatre contacts
dans les écoles alors au total en
décembre on a fait plus d'un million de
tests et en janvier on va faire plus du
double ce qui fera une facture je vous
le disais de plus d'un milliard d'euros
alors qu'ils payent majoritairement
c'est l'état et l'assurance maladie
parce que la majorité des tests sont
prescrits par les médecins ou demander
parce qu'il y a des symptômes et dans le
cas s'il ya des symptômes et si c'est
prescrit par un médecin mais à l'épée
sierre et les objets ils ne sont pas
payés par les patients et sur d'autres
payé par l'administration les patients
eux payent ce qu'on a appelé les tests
de confort c'est à dire tout ce qu'on
passait parce que on n'était pas
vaccinée ou qui étaient nécessaires pour
obtenir le past le pass sanitaire celui
qu'on est en train de remplacer
aujourd'hui par le passé vaccinale les
autres tests sont payants ils sont
payants sauf pour les enfants qui ont à
qui on a donné deux autres tests par
semaine en corse n'est pas très clair là
il va falloir vérifier mais c'est très
compliqué parce que l'état a changé le
protocole et d'une façon générale l'état
a quand même essayé de tout un léger
parce que ça devenait très très lourd il
y avait un encombrement des pharmacies
un encombrement des laboratoires et à un
encombrement des procès alors question
cruciale jean marc est ce que ces tests
sont utiles alors c'est vrai qu'on peut
se poser la question parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens de positif qui n'ont
pas de symptômes et l'administration n'a
pas fait les traçages on trace mais on
voit bien que l'administration n'a pas
le temps de vous suis je vous disais que
je sortais d'un coup vite j'ai été
informé par sms à deux ou trois reprises
pendant une semaine que j'allais
recevoir un coup de téléphone de
l'assurance maladie pour qu'on me
demande mes quatre contacts en fait on
l'a pas fait parce que je pense que les
services sont complètement encombré or
de donner les cas contactez permettrait
de savoir si on peut aller beaucoup plus
loin c'est une question de
responsabilité
espace d'administration a décidé le
public c'est les gens tester et
contaminé prendre leurs responsabilités
alors c'est quand même utile parce que
normalement le testing positif doit
inciter les contaminés à s'isoler rester
chez eux pourquoi parce que d'isolement
permet de limiter la le confinement ils
permettent de limiter la circulation on
aurait bien sûr plus isolé tout le monde
c'était le confinement en comme celui
qu'on a eu en 2020 mais mieux vaut
isoler ceux qui sont contaminés
contagieux mieux vaut isolés notamment
les cadres à ceux qui risquent une
hospitalisation je rappelle que
l'objectif c'est celui-là c'est de
limiter l'état grave donc vaccination
d'un côté surveillance de l'autre alors
si on parle de coups bas il faut savoir
qu'une journée de soins intensifs ça
coûte à l'hôpital 2000 euros par jour 1
et une journée en réanimation ça coûte
3000 euros alors si vous comparez ces
3000 euros par jour auprès d'une
vaccination ou reprises un test y'a pas
photo il faut vraiment passer par part
par la vaccination et surtout quand on
sait qu une réanimation peut prendre la
place d'un opérés cardiaques plus
l'opération pensèrent on a quand même
intérêt à éviter l'arrêt est ce que
globalement on sait combien coûte la
crise pandémique tout compris un oui
alors on en parle assez peu mais on la
cour des comptes fait j'ai des calculs
quotidien là dessus hein on sait qu'en
2020 par exemple sur toute l'année de
2000 ou 2021 et 2021 la hausse des
dépenses publiques liées aux kovy a été
de 96 milliards d'euros par an c'est à
dire 80 6% de plus que la normale en a
fait on a fait 100 milliards par an à
peu près en 2009 2010 9 devient 2020
2021 l'une moitié sur les dépenses de
santé supplémentaires l'hôpital tu es ce
vaccin une autre moitié sont les
dépenses de soutien économique
c'est-à-dire le plan de solidarité je
pense que 2022 va être du même ordre la
vraie question c'est de savoir si on
peut payer tout ça là la réponse à mon
avis est celle des économistes est assez
est assez unanimes c'est que oui on peut
le payer dans la mesure dans la mesure
seulement où ces dépenses ont permis une
reprise très forte de l'économie si on
n'avait pas finalement su soigner la
pandémie maintenir les entreprises
notamment en état de fonctionnement on
aurait sans doute pas payer ce prix là
donc on peut certes critiqué la
stratégie parce qu'elle a été flou il ya
eu des erreurs mais on est quand même
obligé de reconnaître que cette
stratégie a peint
les relations du virus pour que
l'économie puisse fonctionner et
finalement ça a été quand même 1 paraît
relativement bon mais à bonne escient
puisque on a réussi finalement à
contenir le le montant des dépenses dans
des limites possibles et acceptable pour
l'instant merci beaucoup jean-marc
l'édito écoute jean marc sylvestre à
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux